I don't think the political philosophers
have any,
have any special insight into,
um,
into everyday politics as I,
as I suggested before,
most political philosophers are more
interested in philosophy than in
politics.
So that doesn't give them any,
um,
any handle on what's going on in the
world,
in my experience in the academic world
is that,
that academics are not much more
intelligent about everyday issues then
than ordinary citizens.
Um,
they are more knowledgeable.
They can call up historical references,
but that doesn't mean they get things
right here and hearing now.
Hose John Edwards was the candidate most
committed to an organized campaign to
reduce any qualities in American
society.
And he didn't get very far this,
uh,
this time.
Um,
I,
I suppose I,
I think that Hillary Clinton is,
um,
is of the remaining to the most like a
European social democratic politician,
a policy wonky with a lot of ideas about
concretely what ought to be done.
Um,
and with all the compromises that social
democratic politicians always ended up
making,
um,
and Obama is,
is from my perspective,
a relatively unknown,
uh,
quality.
He,
um,
I suppose he is a centrist Democrat and
any,
any Democrat centrist,
right or left is going to,
um,
is going to change the way America has
been moving in the last eight years,
maybe in the last 40 years.
Um,
but how,
how committed he is to change.
I know he's committed to the rhetoric of
change,
but how committed he is to actual
concrete change on the ground and how
prepared he is to fight the necessary
fights which will be very partisan and
very ugly in.
Won't permit him to ride above partisan
conflict the way he has been doing in
the,
in the campaign.
How prepared he is for that.
I don't,
I don't know.